small towns built around a single
industry run the risk of having to
reinvent them reinvent themselves if the
employer closes up shop that's what
happened in the small South Dakota city
of lead nestled in the state's Black
Hills lead was once home to the largest
gold mine in North America but when it
closed in 2002 the town took a big hit
hundreds of workers lost their jobs and
many left in search of work but Jim
Axelrod learned the future of lead could
hinge on people going back underground
to dig into a very different matter
Jim good morning well good morning lead
was a company town without a company but
then some very smart people realized
there was something maybe even more
valuable than gold sitting underneath
the homes and streets the gaping hole in
the middle of lead South Dakota is a
reminder of the town's Golden Age that
Mayor Ron Everett just can't ignore when
we look at this enormous hole in the
ground what story does that tell us
about lead well this this is what what
you can see from the mining activity for
a hundred and thirty years there's 300
miles of underground workings down there
for years the Homestake goldmine was the
largest and deepest gold mine in North
America producing more than 40 million
ounces of gold at its peak it employed
2,200 people and supported a vibrant
community with virtually no unemployment
all the guys put a little heater on
their deck City Commissioner David
vardaman was a geologist at home state
lead was the economic engine of South
Dakota these were the highest paid
salaries in South Dakota we drove all of
the economy in the local area gold was
booming 44 years ago CBS News last
visited the mine in lead
but after years of increasing production
costs and declining prices the mine shut
down in the early 2000s hundreds of
people lost their jobs including Luke
Scott so when you heard Homestake was
closing
how'd you process that it's pretty hard
to process that I mean it was it was
tough because then you got a sorry find
another job you know but there isn't a
lot of jobs for miners in this area
another mining town with a shutdown
mined lead could have taken a dive but
it avoided that fate by taking a dive
nearly a mile beneath the surface after
suiting up in protective clothes boots
and hard hats we crowded into an
elevator like cage and descended four
thousand eight hundred fifty feet below
the surface along for the ride David
vardaman and Luke Scott who both got new
jobs at the old mine in this country
when the good jobs go away in a place
like a mine they usually don't come back
yeah it's very very lucky I'm just
fortunate that I get to come back here
and do what I like to do and I like to
be underground
here a new kind of mining is taking
place in the deepest cleanroom in the
world where once again we change this
time into special sterile suits to see
where a team of world-class scientists
like abadan Kristofferson is mining for
the secrets of the universe it's not
enough to just glove up if you're gonna
work in here you gotta actually then go
through these rubber arms yes and then
put another pair of gloves on you put
gloves on top of the girls on top of
welcome to the Sanford underground
research facility so far under the earth
that all the radiation and noise from
the Sun is filtered out creating a place
where researchers can work in an ultra
pure environment here Christopherson a
chemist grows the world's purest copper
to use in experiments you are wrestling
with the most fundamental questions of
humanity correct of why matter exists in
the universe if at the time of the Big
Bang you had equal amounts of matter and
antimatter they should have met and
annihilated each other so why are we
here rather than shrinking lead is now
growing all on account of some masterful
repurposing the next stage
laughs exploring these concepts will be
conducted here yeah where we're heading
exactly over the next decade a new
billion-dollar international physics
project will be built half a mile from
Kristofferson's lab in another part of
the old Homestake mine the next phase of
this cutting-edge research will actually
unfold on the other side correct just
about 200 feet away and another influx
of scientists and visitors will be
expected in lead which is still trying
to fill empty storefronts and revive its
economy oh that this place starts to
become a business district again around
science home steak was here for a long
time
they provided jobs security the lab is
going to be here for a long time
there'll be jobs they'll be security
what those jobs are don't know but
there's still some gold in these hills
yes now scientists just knew Homestake
would be perfect for this kind of
research because half a century ago a
chemist named Ray Davis convinced the
mine owners to let him build a small lab
underground and the work he did there
later won him a Nobel Prize Wow really
interesting stuff
it really is glad to be back up here I
feel close to Michael and I feel
claustrophobic tonight yeah yeah but I
knew I was coming up yeah you knew you
were coming back to us yeah if they keep
Jim Axelrod